A study published in the journal Lancet ranked
heroin as the second most harmful to users
and to others.
And it’s one of the most addictive, according
to the National Institute on Drug abuse,
But it’s also one the most deadly, according
to the World Health Organization, heroin users
face a 20 to 30 times higher risk of death
than non-drug users.
So how is the drug so powerful?
Well like most opioids it works on certain
receptors in the brain.
Your brain has receptors for endorphins, the
feel good chemicals your body naturally produces.
They help us handle pain and stress by inhibiting
the firing of neurons.
But opioids like heroin have similar chemical
structure as those endorphins.
So they bind to those receptor sites, sometimes
even more strongly than the natural ones in
your body.
According to a study published
in the Journal of Neuroscience, frequent heroin
injections actually desensitize these receptors.
They get so stimulated they kind of wear themselves
out.
So over time a user will have to increase
their dosage just to get the same feeling.
Heroin users reportedly feel a “rush”
lasting just a few minutes that produces an
intense relaxation.
Afterwards, the “high” lasts for a few
hours,where users feel like they don’t have
a care in the world and don’t need a thing.
They aren’t really bothered by much in their
environment.
Speaking of environment, the weird thing is,
it’s not just the high that gets you addicted.
It’s the associations.
Seriously.
A study published in The Journal of Neuroscience
found that using heroin literally flips a
switch in a part of your called the basolateral
amygdala.
This switch links the high of the drug with
environmental triggers.
Your brain rewires itself to respond more
strongly to these memories.
These neural pathways get stronger over time
and your ability to form new ones gets worse.
You lose what’s called neural plasticity,
which makes it harder to resist the urge to
use when you come across these triggers.
But on the other hand, there’s been some
research that suggests people turn to heroin
to escape their environment.
Research from Columbia University's Mailman
School of Public Health linked heroin use
to disadvantaged neighborhoods and stressful
lives.
But there’s no doubt that heroin is dangerous.
It’s a drug especially prone to deadly overdose.
I mean it’s not exactly a regulated industry,
so hits can vary in purity.
Someone who is used to using 10% pure heroin
mixed with other stuff, might purchase some
that’s 60% pure heroin, but there’s no
good way to tell the difference.
The drug’s deadly effects come from it’s
relaxing properties.
Basically while you relax, it can suppress
your respiratory system, to the point where
you body forgets to breathe.
yeah, not good.
Heroin can also cause some serious heart problems
too.
Even leading
to a heart attack.